this is the actual robbie the robot that
was used in the making of the film
robbie was built by the mgm prop
department and has become certainly one
of the most popular robot icons in movie
history in forbidden planet dr morbius
played by walter pidgeon demonstrates
that robbie is programmed to follow the
three laws of robotics originally
conceived in the 1940s by science
fiction writer isaac azeboth number one
a robot may not injure a human being
number two a robot must obey human
orders number three a robot must protect
its own existence
in the 1970s robbie was on public
display at the movie museum in buena
park california the museum eventually
closed and robbie was sold to a private
collector
we have a special guest and someone who
hasn't made an appearance actually in 50
years
who actually was in forbidden planet
so joining us on stage why don't we have
somebody who i think you know who is
come and join us
oh thank you robbie
here's your audience
does anybody in the audience have any
questions for uh robbie anyone out there
would like to answer questions yes how
about you
how do you move the question is how do
you move robbie how do you move
if professor mobius wanted humans to
have that knowledge he would have given
it to them
the mysteries of the krell
robbie john lannis wants to know how
they melted the krell's steel
the powers of the id are so remarkable
no force in the known universe can
withstand them
how does the blue light work robbie when
you talk
the blue light was added for humans it
allowed them to consider my voice more
natural
in the absence of lips
you